hello everyone again uh florentressler
here um welcome to pi data global 2021
i'm very excited to
yeah have brandon collins talk here
brandon is a software developer with
expertise in data science and geospatial
technology he's a co-founder and
principal at a make path a geospatial
data science company founded in austin
texas
i skipped over some of the bits so we
can get started with the talk but he
is
has worked for companies including
microsoft anaconda nvidia ncx bad
conversation international
and new fortress forests sorry about
that and today he'll be talking about
spatial analytics using task and numbers
so i'm really excited about that and
over to you brendan
great thank you florian um i'm going to
go ahead and share my screen here
like i said really really happy to be
here um and um i love pi data events and
i love the pi data software ecosystem um
my uh my name is brennan collins i'm the
co-founder and principal at make path
we're a spatial data science firm
located in austin texas and we have a
heavy skew towards open source and open
source contribution and love projects
which
focus on geospatial analytics
if you'd like to learn more about our
work you can go over to make path dot
com forward slash blog where you can see
some of our recent projects and um and
announcements this year has been a heavy
year for us on um the bokeh
visualization library where we've been
working to
increase support for latex and also
publication quality exports from bokeh
so we're big fans of um of bokeh and um
but today
i'm going to be focused more on x-ray
spatial so this is coming over to my
github page here which shows some of the
open source projects that um that we
contribute to
x-ray spatial is one that we created
inside of make path and now actively
maintain
which is focused on
raster-based spatial analytics
and
to get going you can go to um xray
spatial.org where you can find our
documentation page which talks a little
bit about the project and some of its
value propositions
for folks that aren't as familiar with
the geospatial world
we tend to have two different
fundamental types of data
and data representations one is the
raster flavor which are regular grids
and the other is a
is vector data which vector is certainly
a term used in a lot of different
domains but in the geospatial world it
re refers to points lines and polygons
so
these two areas are you'll find
represented in different open source
projects and the aim of x-ray spatial is
to provide analysis functions on top of
rasters
these rasters many times are appropriate
for representing continuous phenomena so
you you think of things like elevation
rainfall
temperature soil acidity things that
lend themselves to rasters while the
vector side of geospatial tends to be
discrete phenomena so when we think of
road center lines that's appropriate for
a vector or we think of administrative
boundaries which are polygons which we
would put in the vector category of
geospatial data
xray spatial is focused on the raster
side
so um you can come over to also
github.com forward slash make path for
x-ray spatial
this is the project home page and it
will also
walk you through some of the
functionality inside of this library
um some of the main features
of the library are that it was built
using number and desk and that's what
i'm going to be going deeper into during
the presentation
it also does not have any dependencies
on gdal or geos which are foundational
libraries for open source geospatial
analytics but we wanted to have a
python library which could be easily
extended by folks in the python
community that didn't need you to drop
down to like a c or c plus level to read
the core algorithms or to extend the
core functions inside the library
we aim to be able to make obviously make
those fast so as we're looping over
millions of pixels we need those
operations to be fast and that's why we
use number i'll talk a little bit more
about number but then we also need the
analysis functions to scale across
multiple cores or multiple machines and
that's where das comes in to help us out
so you can
install x-ray spatial using pip or conda
you can pull this off of the condo forge
conda channel
and then
along with installing x-ray spatial you
get several cli commands that will set
you up with some example notebooks an
example data sets to explore the
different features inside the library
but those features break down into a
a handful of categories
we have 1d classification functions what
these do is these are just general
binning functions if you are familiar
with say say cut or cue cut from pandas
this is similar but operates on top of
um xray data arrays
focal analysis tools which are
calculating summary statistics
around a single pixel so it's putting a
kernel over an image to generate an
image of a similar size
multi-spectral tools which are used for
doing classic band math on satellite
imagery like landsat and sentinel data
the most famous of these tools would
probably be
ndvi but there's many flavors of ndvi in
combining different bands
and as we look at this
this feature table here you're going to
see four columns which indicate
the x-ray back-ends which are supported
by each tool so in the case of an x-ray
data array we are actually wrapping a
numpy array so that's one style of x-ray
data array is wrapping an in-memory
numpy array we can also wrap dash arrays
so those would be
potentially distributed arrays that have
a very similar syntax to the pipe to the
numpy api
and then also
coupe high for um uh kudu-enabled gpus
so coupe is basically like a subset of
the numpy api implemented on top of
cuda's and then also the the
cluster of gpus case where we want to
use gpus as a dash array
so those are multi-spectral tools and
you can see this functionality repeated
for the other areas of what we currently
support and
and what we don't we're aiming to
support all of these backends for all of
the analysis tools as part of a 1.0
release which we're still working
towards
pathfinding tools which will help you
find the shortest path
on a grid
proximity tools which
allow you to
generate distance grids so if you wanted
to say
take a an image that has a bunch of
target pixels we could calculate the
distance um from all the other pixels to
those targets in several different
flavors of it
surface analysis tools which are things
like
slope calculations on terrains aspect
which is what direction is the hill face
facing
procedural terrain generation
view shed is particularly interesting
and we now have very good
coupe i support there which isn't isn't
reflected here but i'll show show it a
little later
um and then uh very useful zonal tools
so the zonal tools module will allow you
to do summary stats by irregular areas
on top of an image this an example of
this would be
say you have one image which represents
administrative boundaries and you want
to calculate say the average slope um
within each administrative boundary that
would be a zonal operation and it would
be appropriate for the zonal tools here
and some local tools which i won't go
too deep into
but overall all of these tools take
x-ray data arrays as input and give
x-ray data arrays as output
there's no new data structures which are
introduced by x-ray spatial which is one
of the the nice things here we didn't
want to introduce new data um structures
we also do not handle io
so we allow other libraries to do things
like load data from
different types of formats
as long as you get your data into an
x-ray data array you can use these
utilities on top of it so if you were
coming from
numpy and all of this is ultimately
based on numpy right as the as the
fundamental data structure to give us
that nd array
um if you're coming from numpy then you
may think of you funks or universal
functions on top of the nd array
x array spatial is essentially
additional universal functions for
spatial functionality on top of
2d arrays
xray itself you may not be familiar with
although it is a very very popular
library these days
adds labels to numpy arrays so
very very much like how pandas adds
labels to numpy arrays to create the
data frame or give us a excel worksheet
style data structure
x-array is adding labels um for
potentially multi-dimensional images
uh so we can refer to x and y um not
in indexing using integers but indexing
using strings that makes the code much
more
readable and maintainable in the future
as you don't you know need to just be
indexing using integers and numpy arrays
but what's nice is that if you have an
x-ray data array you can always bail out
of x-ray and just do dot data and you
have that underlying numpy array so
there's really nice synergy between um
numpy and x-ray x-ray also supports das
so
we have nice support for das through
xray and then can write blocked
algorithms on top of
das backed x-ray data rates
so
number is one of the core dependencies
of x-ray spatial because we use it for
implementing all of our algorithms
number is a just-in-time compiler for
python and also understands numpy arrays
so
as we're taking a functioning and
jitting it and we're going to look at an
example of that coming up
that jitted function can take numpy
arrays as input and give numpy arrays as
output and that's uh that's really nice
and so that's why we're using number is
to speed up all of the algorithms inside
of x-ray spatial so number represents
what i call our vertical
scaling solution
on the horizontal axis of scaling or
being able to run these algorithms on
multiple cores or multiple machines we
use das and that's the what the dashed
back end is for is to be able to have
partitioned arrays that have a very
similar syntax in using them as
numpy
and then
we can write functions on top of those
desk arrays do things like say a slope
calculation or a hillshade calculation
but be using a dash array and have that
um actually
resolved across a cluster as opposed to
just having to to rely on one machines
in memory um capacity
and then coupe i mentioned a little bit
about kupai but kupai is the library
you'd use to
have an array on top of a cuda enabled
gpu
our general philosophy in x-ray spatial
is that you give us a xray data array
and we
introspect that array and identify what
type of array is that it's using is it
using numpy dash or coupei and then
we'll return the same object to use so
if you send in a
an xray data array that's backed by a
dash array then that's what you'll get
back from the analysis function so there
isn't any flags to set like hey use a
gpu or not if you send us a coupon
array we'll do our best to use a gpu
that's that's
there um
it would be a little remiss to not
mention um how vector data ties in here
so geopandas is a really great library
for managing
vector data so this would be
the equivalent of adding a geometry
column into a pandas data frame is
essentially what geopandas does but then
has also um
geospecific functions on top of the
geometry so geopandas adds the geoseries
so that we can store points lines and
polygons but many times we need to bring
those vectors into a raster based
analysis
and that's where we can take a geopandas
geodata frame
and feed it through a project called
data shader xray spatial actually fell
out of data shader because i was adding
um a lot of geo functionality to data
shader and finally we looked at looked
at and said you know what let's keep
data shader as just a rasterization
pipeline and all this additional
functionality can move out and that was
the the beginnings of of x-ray spatial
but data shader is a general purpose
rasterization pipeline that will help
you in aligning any of your vector data
with other raster data so inside of data
shader we can take say a bunch of
polygons and we can rasterize them to
the same resolution as say a satellite
image and then be able to do our zonal
operations between the two data sources
so just a
shout out to data shader which is a
really really nice nice project
so when you come to
the x-ray spatial
github page and you install the the
library you can access also
example notebooks this is in the the
user guide area of x-ray spatial some of
them include surface tools we try to
have one for each of the major
categories of of analysis tools
and you can see a little bit about of
how you'd actually execute these tools
so we're starting by generating a a
terrain that's just purlin noise
um we're adding some color mapping and
this is using data shader to do the
actual
color stretch from on a pseudoelevation
color map
but then here we see say an x-ray
spatial tool
and this is
the style of how you call the tools from
x-ray spatial you would import
the tool in this case it's a hill shade
and then you'd pass in an x-ray data
array and then you'd get an x-ray data
right back from there you could shade it
using data shader or you could save it
to disk using x-ray but
this analysis tool is the part that's
really x-ray spatial so there's uh this
these notebooks cover many a different
many different tools
and could certainly spend a lot of time
just on one notebook but i also wanted
to show
proximity tools
so here within proximity tools
this is particularly useful tool set for
feature engineering so if you're trying
to pull out new features for your model
and think that spatial
relationships could be important then
you may take a look at using the
proximity tools to do things like hey
what's the distance at this pixel to the
nearest gas station maybe that could be
an interesting question or dimension to
add into your model so i encourage folks
to not just think okay this is just for
geospatial folks these tools also very
much lend themselves to just general
general ml
here we start with
a bunch of target pixels
these are we can think of as our
locations that we're going to calculate
distance to
and then we run them through
x-ray spatial proximity function and we
generate out a distance map
where each pixel would be
the distance to the nearest target
and there's different flavors of doing
distance analysis so just the raw
distance is one and you can obviously
change a distance metric in this case
we're using a great circle distance but
then there's also distance tools like
and we can obviously threshold things
but allocation so distance allocation
would say
hey i want to generate a grid but i want
the pixel value to be the id of the
nearest feature not the actual raw
distance
or another you know flavor of that would
be i want the bearing or direction to
the nearest target pixel so these are
some of the
proximity functions that we support in
x-ray spatial
then also the zonal tools i just wanted
to show real quick um using zonal tools
in this case um it may be a little
difficult to see but we have a a fake
terrain here and i have a lot some line
features that go across the terrain that
represent a
a hypothetical height
where each um segment is one day of the
height
and we want to calculate some summary
statistics about the terrain for each
day of the height and that's where we
can use zonal stats tools we can feed in
our lines as our
zones and then we have values underneath
which are in the elevation raster that
that's below
those lines and what we get back here
this would be one example of not getting
a x-ray data right back in this case you
get a pandas data frame that's indexed
by the id of each one of the zones and
then has summary stats for each one of
the zones and you can define your own
functions
for how to calculate those summary stats
so here i've written a
a simple function and that will inside
of this function when it's called i'll
only have the pixels that apply for that
zone and i can do more
subtle calculations on just the pixels
of that zone so these are zonal
statistics tools
in a little bit into the code so if you
say hey i'm not that interested in the
spatial stuff but you are interested in
number and desk i would encourage you to
go and dive into the x-ray spatial code
and um slope might be a good one to look
at
here if we scroll down in slope to look
at some of the code here and make it a
little bigger
we can see um
[Music]
the uh so this is horn slope it's the
you know the first derivative of the
elevation
and we can see the cpu implementation of
horn slope which uses number for
speedups
um a little ways down
we can see the gpu implementation
and um as we keep going we can see so
there are some some things that we're
still still working out here this
probably uh could be could be fixed but
we can see the use of dask's
map overlap which is um a shows you on
the on the desk side how you can write a
function which deals with overlapping
partitions on your dash array so if you
need the edges on one partition to do
something like calculated neighborhood
then you can use the map overlaps
function inside of das to do that and
then these are all um coordinated
together in a public
method or public function called slope
that will figure out um what type of
array back-end you're using and then
call the appropriate
slope function based on the array that
you pass in
so right now x-ray spatial is being used
in a couple of places one of them is the
microsoft planetary computer the
planetary computer for folks that don't
know is um is a initiative from
microsoft to combine curated data sets
with um scalable compute and open source
tools so we have a data catalog that
is uh is has tons of different imagery
and then um we can run jupiter hub on
top of it and this is what uh the
microsoft computer looks like if you
were to actually log in so we're logged
in to
to the uh planetary computer right now
we have a bunch of tutorial notebooks
that lead you through different analyses
with x-ray spatial and other tools
and you can run them all
on das clusters
posted on on azure access through
jupyter lab so this is a really nice
tool from microsoft that um you can see
uh x-ray spatial in action
then also we've been having fun recently
just trying to say like what what parts
of x-ray spatial would benefit the most
from better gpu support so we chose um
you know four different areas over the
last couple of weeks to just focus on
better gpu
support and performance um terrain
generation view shed and um and hill
shading
now while a lot of our um the benchmarks
where we were comparing a single core
cpu to a single gpu
have to be taken with a grain of salt
like we can see hey in the example of
generating purlin noise our cpu
implementation was taking 25 seconds on
this 4000 by 2000 pixel grid while uh
the the cuda version was blowing it out
of the water but these have to be taken
with a grain of salt because this is
just a single core cpu so the cpu
implementation could be different and
then also um uh this you know could be
could scale to say if we had 20 cpus
what would that performance be but it
still yields some some very nice results
from um focusing on poopai and uh cuda
on top of with x-ray spatial
um we also did this for view shed to
make a um a cuda enabled view shed
viewshed would be
having an observer at a specific height
and then identifying those pixels within
the grid that are in direct line of
sight from uh from the user
um we did this also with our basic hill
shade which is just a three by three
calculation
of normals around a pixel but then um
also we did a
ray tracing version of hill shade which
allows you to actually put more
realistic shadows on the terrain
um we got very good performance um
boosts from from both of those
but i wanted to show a quick video um
and this is a video of xray spatial and
then as we click on a spot in the
terrain we're going to be calculating
the view shed from that observer um as
the video is going you can see that the
shadows are changing because we're doing
ray casting on top of the terrain and
this was one of the demos that we
created as part of our fun with with
gpus over the last couple of weeks this
is crater lake national park and all the
um the illumination and the view shed is
coming from
x-ray spatial
um
so then uh let me just do this guy
so i would encourage folks to go over to
xra spatial you know we're always
looking for for new contributors and um
it you know if if you have questions i'm
always always happy to answer them now
or um
uh have folks message me uh afterwards
thanks so much for the talk um we
already have one question uh from
the question was can x-ray apply
interpolation techniques for regular
gridding spatial data
yeah so there's different types of
interpolation that you can do on top of
x-ray data arrays
so
one is that you know you could look at a
library like data shader which can
handle resampling of of arrays
but then
also in doing selections on x-ray
objects you can give it a nearest
argument that would allow you to
interpolate the value and snap to the
nearest coordinate of the input value so
say you're putting in a point and that
point isn't is not aligned to the grid
um you can use some interpolation there
to uh select the pixel or to select the
value um based on a nearest operation
there's they're probably more subtle to
that question than then i fully uh grasp
but happy to go deeper
excellent um i think chad we have a
question from
majid
she's saying
she's just curious if it's possible to
write those operations as tensors a
tensor operation like torture tensorflow
so right now this is all
done
using numpy
and the numpy memory model
x-ray itself right um has a heavy focus
on net cdf and replicates the net cdf
model in memory
so
if there's there could be some maybe
some data conversion but if you're
staying within the um the numpy world
then it will be easy to take any of the
the intermediate data from x-ray spatial
and convert it into a into um like
flatten it or do anything that you need
to do depending on on where you know
what array format you need
so numpy is the ultimate answer to that
this is at the end of the day there's
numpy arrays here in the background
so far i have no further questions and i
can't see the q a anymore
so i i hope
yeah thank you again brandon like that
was a
a great talk i really like the the speed
comparison they always make a big impact
and
[Laughter]
and yeah good good luck i also like the
spatial computer
integration i think i recently worked
with that that's really great like so
again thank you so much i'll try to sort
out my login issues for the next talk
yeah have have fun everyone
please continue the conversation on
on slack and gather the town and again
thanks to you brendan thank you guys
you